Rene is with us in winston-salem North
Carolina hi Rene how are you hi Dave I'm
better than I deserve
laughter how are you good how can I help
I was calling because I had a situation
to happen over the weekend I'm dating a
person I've been dating them for almost
a year now and we've talked about
various types of subjects we talked
about many subjects we were talking
marriage so we were talking about money
he told me a certain about income that
he made he told me where he was on his
financial cycle
well it's tax time he needed help with
his taxes try the disguises and I found
out that he didn't he doesn't make the
amount that he said he made does he make
more or less
he made less and it kind of set me back
because I asked him about it and he got
kind of defensive and he was like wise I
was telling you about a raise but I
didn't get that raise but it's a
significantly lower even if you know
what I tell you he may he he's beginning
in his field so now when did he tell you
in the conversation that he told a lie
when they tell you he made he
pacifically said he made $13 an hour
okay and what does he actually make on
the tax return he only made 15,000 for
the whole year okay so that's because
significantly less than $13 an hour I
would guess and say the reason he lied
was he was ashamed but I didn't
understand because how can you do that
rhaggy lied and I don't think that's
okay but I'm guessing and say he lied
because he's ashamed they doesn't make
much money but how do you move for it I
don't know if you do I don't know if you
do because if you can't trust somebody
to tell you the truth about that you
can't trust somebody tell you the truth
about other stuff what else is he going
to be doing that he's ashamed of that he
doesn't want to tell you
I also found out that a utility that he
said what it was in his name is not even
in his name so holder I'm I'm 38 and
he's 14 48 yeah if you were talking to a
22 year old that came to you for counsel
and they told you this about their
boyfriend what would you tell them now
there's your answer this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim